House of the Dragon is the new Game of Thrones
prequel show. It's set two hundred years before
Game of Thrones – and it’s about the Targaryen
family, Daenerys Targaryen’s ancestors,
back when they ruled Westeros at the height of
their power. This is a story of ambition and
politics, betrayal and revenge, dragons, and a lot
of really angry blond people. The show is based on
a book called Fire & Blood, by George Martin.
George co-created this show with Ryan Condal,
and they say it’s a faithful adaptation of the
book. George has a nickname for House of the
Dragon – he calls it Hot D. There are a bunch
of new trailers and interviews out for Hot D,
so what do they reveal, and what can we expect
from the new show? This video has no spoilers,
just introduces the characters and world.
So – quick history – the Targaryens are the
royal dynasty of Westeros. But originally, the
Targaryens came from Valyria, the old empire
of the dragonlords in the east. Valyria was
destroyed in the mysterious Doom of Valyria,
and the Targaryens were the only dragon-riders to
survive – cause the Targaryens had already left
Valyria, and settled on Dragonstone, an island off
Westeros. Aegon Targaryen, with his sister-wives
and their dragons, conquered the Seven Kingdoms,
forged the Iron Throne, and became the first King
of Westeros. After him was King Aenys, then
King Maegor, then King Jaehaerys, and in House
of the Dragon, the king is Viserys Targaryen.
The basic story in Hot D is that King Viserys
wants his daughter, Princess Rhaenyra, to take
the Throne and rule after him. But some people
have other plans for the Throne – including the
king’s brother Daemon, and the King’s Hand Otto,
and Otto’s daughter Alicent. But this conflict
builds up slowly, with tensions rising over
years and years. So Hot D occasionally
jumps forward in time several years,
to show how the politics and relationships
gradually change. Alicent and Rhaenyra are
played by different actors as they age – like
in The Crown. Co-creator Ryan Condal said this
is “a generational war” – and the time span lets
us fully understand these characters, and their
history, before the “first sword stroke falls”.
So Viserys Targaryen is king, and he inherited
a peaceful and prosperous realm from Jaehaerys.
So Viserys’ reign became the apex of Targaryen
power and wealth. That’s reflected in the size
of the Iron Throne in Hot D – it’s bigger and
grander – compared to how it looks in Game of
Thrones. The new design is also closer to how
the Throne is described in the books – as a huge
monstrosity of metal, forged from the swords of
King Aegon’s enemies. In Game of Thrones, dragons
are almost extinct. But in Hot D, the Targaryens
have lots of dragons, and that’s how they dominate
Westeros. Dragons are weapons of mass destruction,
they’re like the nuclear bombs of this world,
and since only the Targaryens have dragons,
no one can mess with them. When Viserys was
younger, he rode the dragon Balerion, the biggest
and baddest Targaryen dragon. But Balerion
soon died of old age, and Viserys hasn’t ridden
a dragon since. In a trailer, he calls dragons
“a power man should never have trifled with”,
like they’re too dangerous to be controlled.
Cause King Viserys is “a man of peace”, he just
wants everyone to get along and have a good time.
So he hosts feasts, and balls and tournaments,
he’s popular with the lords and common folk.
Viserys is a good man. But being a good man
doesn’t make you a good king. And times
of peace can sow the seeds of war.
In a trailer, Viserys describes a dream
of his heir, and the Throne, and dragons.
In the books, many Targaryens have prophetic
dragon dreams that can tell the future.
But often these dreams are.. misinterpreted
and lead to the dreamer’s downfall – Aemon
Targaryen says his brothers dreamed of dragons,
and those dreams “killed them, every one”.
Dragon dreams can be a metaphor for ambition
and the dangers of ambition. Viserys’ actor
Paddy Considine says that Viserys has an ego, and
he wants a legacy – “there is a dragon in him”.
So Viserys is a complicated guy. Author George
Martin said he’s impressed with Considine’s
performance, giving Viserys a “tragic
majesty” that he never had in the books.
One of the biggest problems for Viserys is his
brother, Prince Daemon Targaryen. Daemon is like
the opposite of Viserys. Cause while Viserys
is peaceful, Daemon is violent and impulsive.
Actor Matt Smith said “Daemon is there to cause
chaos and piss people off”. Daemon rides the
red dragon Caraxes, called “the Blood Wyrm”, and
Daemon’s personality is reflected in his dragon’s
personality – Caraxes is “like a huge rabid
dog”, volatile and chaotic. There are at least
17 dragons in this story – and the showrunners
say we’ll meet nine of them in Season 1.
Each dragon has a distinct personality,
colour, and look – some of them are “bearded,
like tropical lizards”. Apparently Caraxes is a
“deformed” dragon with a super long neck and extra
wings on his hind legs. These unique designs
contrast with the dragons in Game of Thrones,
which were almost impossible to tell apart –
despite their colourful descriptions in the books.
Prince Daemon is a great warrior. He
wields the legendary Valyrian steel sword
Dark Sister, once used by Queen Visenya
– and used by King Maegor the Cruel.
In the trailers, we see Daemon leading
the City Watch of King’s Landing,
called the gold cloaks – we saw the gold cloaks
in Game of Thrones betraying Ned in Season 1,
and buying.. crab aphrodisiacs in Season 7.
Cause Daemon is Commander of the City Watch,
and he’s the one who first gave
the Watch their gold cloaks,
and better armour – so Daemon is why they’re
now called gold cloaks. Daemon gets real
enthusiastic about law enforcement – especially
the part where you cut body parts off criminals.
As Commander of the Watch, he’s known as the
“Prince of the City” or “Lord Flea Bottom”.
Daemon has an estranged wife called Rhea Royce
who he hates, and calls his “bronze bitch”.
Daemon considers himself heir to the Throne,
after Viserys. But Viserys doesn’t want him
on the Throne because he’s such a loose
cannon. Daemon does act sometimes like
just a violent villainous dickhead, but there
are layers to him, and sensitivity. Deep down,
despite their differences, Daemon and Viserys
love each other, and what Daemon really wants is
approval and recognition from his brother. The
books say that Daemon is a hero and a villain,
a “rogue prince” made of both light and darkness.
Princess Rhaenyra is Viserys’ beloved only child,
and he wants her to inherit his Throne. He keeps
her by his side at council so she can learn
politics. Rhaenyra is precocious, beautiful,
and popular at court – singers call her “the
Realm’s Delight”. Rhaenyra has been a dragonrider
since age 7, bonded with the yellow dragon Syrax.
We can see that Targaryens now use saddles to ride
their dragons, which looks a lot more comfortable
than Daenerys did clinging to Drogon’s scaly back
in Game of Thrones. In Hot D, the dragons are kept
at this building called the Dragonpit. And there’s
tradition around dragon eggs – baby Targaryens
often have dragon eggs put in their cribs, so that
they bond with the dragons that hatch from them.
The Targaryens have close relationships with
their dragons – possibly too close historically.
But Rhaenyra has that oldschool Targaryen fiery
personality. Her actor Emma D’Arcy says Rhaenyra
“has to learn when to dampen that fire and when to
trust it” – Rhaenyra has similarities to Daenerys.
You can also compare Rhaenyra to Arya, with her
“rebellious and cheeky spirit”, and her conflict
against society’s gender roles. In the patriarchal
world of Westeros, many lords don’t want
a woman on the Throne. There’s never been a female
ruler of Westeros, and the rules of succession
prefer men to women. So Rhaenyra feels a constant
“battle with what it means to be a woman”,
and how her gender clashes with her political
power – which a similar theme to Cersei’s story.
Rhaenyra’s best friend is Alicent Hightower, the
daughter of the Hand of the King, Otto Hightower.
While Rhaenyra is rebellious, Alicent tends to
follow the rules, and do what’s expected of a
noble lady – kinda like Sansa Stark. In Hot D,
Alicent and Rhaenyra grow up together at court,
and they’re super close, like siblings. Which
is a change from the books – in the books,
Alicent is older than Rhaenyra, and we don’t know
much about her childhood. The book, Fire & Blood,
gives only a broad summary of these events. So
it’s up to the show Hot D, to create much of the
detail of these relationships and personalities.
Alicent came to court with her father, Otto
Hightower. Otto is Hand of the King, so he’s like
the second most powerful person in Westeros – like
how Ned Stark and Tywin Lannister were
Hand of the King in Game of Thrones.
Otto’s family, the Hightowers, are one of the
oldest and richest houses in Westeros. They rule
the city of Oldtown, home of the maesters of the
Citadel and of the High Septon of the Faith of
the Seven. The Hightowers tend to avoid war, and
gain power through trade and politics. In Hot D,
the Lord of Oldtown is Hobert Hightower – he
rules the city, while his brother Otto is at court
as Hand of the King. Otto is a smart strategic
politician, “a pragmatist and a manipulator”.
He’s proud, ambitious and “ruthless” but he also
“struggles” with his decisions. Otto loves his
daughter Alicent, but they don’t communicate well,
and their relationship is complicated by politics.
Otto hates Prince Daemon, and wants to prevent him
from having power. So Otto and Daemon are always
competing for influence over King Viserys.
As well as the Hightowers, another important
family is House Velaryon, led by Lord
Corlys, the Sea Snake. Like the Targaryens,
the Velaryons originally came from Valyria in the
east. But unlike the Targaryens, the Velaryons
aren’t dragon riders. Instead, they love sailing,
and have a powerful fleet of ships. They’re based
on Driftmark, an island near Dragonstone and
King’s Landing – and they’re close allies of the
Targaryens – ruling the seas, while the Targaryens
on their dragons rule the skies. Lord Corlys
Velaryon is a famous adventurer and explorer. He’s
sailed to far-distant places like Qarth, Yi Ti
and Asshai. By trading with these exotic places,
Corlys has made the Velaryons the richest family
in Westeros, even richer than the Lannisters
and Hightowers. Corlys has seen the world and
made a fortune, but he’s still not satisfied
– Corlys has great ambitions for his family.
In Hot D, Corlys and his family are black –
which is a change from the books. In the books,
the Velaryons look like the Targaryens, cause
the two families have been marrying each other
for generations. The Targaryens like to keep
their Valyrian dragon blood in the family,
so when they don’t marry a Velaryon,
they usually marry their sister – so the
Targaryens and Velaryons in books are one big
incestuous family of inbred blondes. In Hot D,
they’ve changed the look. But the Velaryons still
have silver hair, indicating the Valyrian blood
that they share with the Targaryens.
After Corlys’ voyages across the world,
he got married – to Princess Rhaenys Targaryen.
Rhaenys is a cousin of Viserys and Daemon.
Rhaenys’ mother was a Baratheon, so in the in the
books, Rhaenys has black hair. Rhaenys is “fierce
and fearless”, “proud”, smart, and capable.
She’s been a dragonrider since she was thirteen,
riding “Meleys, the Red Queen”. When Rhaenys
married Corlys, she arrived at the wedding on
dragonback. Corlys said “I came back
from the ends of the earth for you”.
And Rhaenys said “We can go back to the ends of
the earth together”, “But I’ll get there first,
as I’ll be flying”. Rhaenys and Corlys
have a deep love, and one of the more
healthy relationships in the story. But Rhaenys
and Corlys also have ambition, and resentment.
Because Rhaenys was the firstborn child of King
Jaehaerys’ firstborn son – so back in the day,
many people saw Rhaenys as the rightful heir
to the Throne. But male rulers are preferred
over women. So King Jaehaerys repeatedly passed
over Rhaenys to make his second son Baelon and
then Baelon’s son Viserys the heir instead. So
Rhaenys is called the Queen who never was. She
and Corlys feel that her birthright, and her
childrens’ birthright, was taken from her.
And this injustice hasn’t been forgotten.
Corlys and Rhaenys have two children, Laena
and Laenor Velaryon. Laena is “fiery”
and “adventurous” like her parents,
and she rides Vhagar, the biggest and
oldest dragon alive. While Laenor rides
the “splendid grey-and-white dragon” Seasmoke.
So those are the three important families in House
of the Dragon. The Targaryens – with King Viserys,
his daughter Rhaenyra, and brother Daemon. The
Hightowers, with Otto and his daughter Alicent.
And the Velaryons, with Corlys, his wife Rhaenys,
and their kids Laena and Laenor. But there
are a few other important characters at court.
Criston Cole is not a prince or a lord from a
great house – he’s the son of a steward. But
he is a talented fighter – and he’s dangerously
hot – “a favorite of all the ladies at court”.
Mysaria is a woman from a brothel in Lys. In
the books she’s described as a “very pale”,
“older woman”, sometimes called “Misery, the White
Worm”. Mysaria is a lover and trusted confident of
Prince Daemon. In Hot D, she’s described as
a survivor with street smarts and ambition.
Lyonel Strong is the Lord of Harrenhal – that
giant half-ruined castle in the riverlands.
Lyonel serves on King Viserys’ council as the
master of laws. He’s a big man, with a reputation
as a warrior, and some people assume he’s a dumb
brute. But Lyonel is very intelligent, having
studied at the Citadel. He brings his sons Harwin
“Breakbones” and Larys “the Clubfoot” to court.
And this guy is Grand Maester Mellos. He advises
the king as representative of the Citadel of the
maester, like Grand Maester Pycelle in Game of
Thrones. Mellos is described as a voice for peace,
“urging calm and compromise”, and is
a “trusted friend” of King Viserys.
Maesters are meant to be unbiased servants,
working for the good of the realm. But some
characters in the books don’t trust the
maesters – Tyrion says the gods only know
who they’re “conspiring with”, or what they
mix into their potions. Another character says
they could be twisting the words of the letters
they read and write for their lords. In Book 5,
this guy Marwyn claims that for centuries,
the maesters have secretly worked against
the Targaryens, to kill off all their dragons.
There’s no proof of any of this in the books,
and Marwyn is kind of a crazy conspiracy theorist.
But if we look closely, Hot D may have hints of
the maesters manipulating politics. Ultimately,
it’s the maesters who write the history books,
and in Fire & Blood, author George Martin plays
with the idea of bias in historical sources.
The main Game of Thrones books are novels,
told from the point of view of the characters
in the moment. But Fire & Blood is different –
it’s s a fictional history book, written by an
in-world historian called Archmaester Gyldayn.
Gyldayn wrote Fire & Blood years after the events
he’s describing, so he relies on historical
sources that are sometimes contradictory.
Two of his sources for the story of Hot D
are a septon called Eustace, a dwarf jester
called Mushroom. While Eustace’s version of
the story is very proper and straightforward,
Mushroom’s version is full of bloody murder
and secret scandalous sex. And it’s up to the
reader to decide whose version of the story
is true. Hot D can only show one version of
events – it’ll be the “objective” account of what
really happened. But we can compare Hot D to the
stories in Fire & Blood to see whether Eustace was
right, or if Mushroom’s scandalous tales are true.
One of the problems with the Game of Thrones
show is that the book series it’s based on isn’t
finished. Thrones ran out of books to adapt in
Season 5, and that’s when the show started getting
worse. Fortunately, Hot D is different, because
the book it’s based on, Fire & Blood, tells the
full story of this conflict from beginning to end.
So the writers know where they’re going this time.
And George Martin is much more involved
than he was in the last seasons of Thrones.
Hot D is a fantasy, but it’s not about
black-and-white heroes-and-villains. Author George
Martin loves “grey characters”, who have both
good and evil in them. Like, in Game of Thrones,
the Starks are mostly heroic, and the Lannisters
are.. mostly villainous, but they’re complicated,
right? Well Hot D is even more morally ambiguous.
Viewers will have different opinions on who the
heroes and the villains are in this story. These
are complex, conflicted characters, who hurt each
other in spectacularly messy ways. There’ll be
high drama, cheating, lies, revenge – “dark,
turbulent, bloody doings”. And we’ll cover it
all with videos each week, so like and subscribe.
We’re gonna do a livestream straight
after each episode of House of the Dragon,
every Sunday at about 10:15pm Eastern time on the
Alt Shift X YouTube channel. Then we’ll make a
video explaining and analysing each episode, like
back in the Game of Thrones days. So subscribe
and press the bell, and follow on Twitter
in case YouTube doesn’t give notifications.
You might also like to subscribe to the Alt Shift
X Podcast – either on YouTube or Spotify or your
podcast app. We might do some interviews and
chats throughout the season. Thank you for
watching, and thanks to the Patrons,
including Anna Lanners, kallmered,
LamePenguin, SporadicSheep, Kim Clark,
Federico Holguín, and Ord X. Cheers.